nestled in the middle of the columbian
mountains the magical madrigals in kanto
is a perfect place there's no war
there's beautiful weather there's plenty
of food there's just one problem they're
also probably inbreeding whoopsie no
diving in today friends cause this gene
pool is shallow but just how bad is it
forget making plants grow or changing
the weather today i'm asking the
question is the real miracle of the
encanto the fact that they've been
avoiding genetic defects for generations
hello internet welcome to film theory
where i'm waiting on a miracle the
miracle of you hitting that subscribe
button so remember that time a few
months ago when i did a theory after
watching encanto one too many times with
my three-year-old well uh we haven't
stopped and months later i still am
trying to force myself to see more and
more details in the animation to try and
keep sane for instance i'll be the first
to admit that it took an embarrassingly
long amount of time for me to realize
that one side of the family wears blue
tones and the other side of the family
wears orange tones and that people who
are in the middle like mirabelle and
bruno have these strong green accents
but there are also plenty of smaller
moments too like here in the opening
song where's this bridge coming from
we're in the middle of the village and
luisa just picks up a random bridge what
is a complete bridge doing in the middle
of the road speaking of inconsistencies
can someone please answer this for me
because it drives me to us every time i
watch the movie or the first set of
cracks that mirabelle sees real after
antonio's ceremony she sees cracks in
the wall but when the family comes
they're all gone so were they real or
were they just a dream because mirabelle
cuts her hand on a broken roof tile so
it had to be real but then did casino
just fix itself or was it actually this
guy have you been in here patching the
cracks oh that no no no no all the
patching's done by hernando who is erna
i'm hernando and i'm scared of nothing
there are also these cool character
moments too like here i love how dolores
is uncomfortable with antonio riding a
jaguar just a funny small blink and you
miss it look speaking of characters who
are uncomfortable well we would expect
isabella to be annoyed by mirabelle and
she clearly is in practically every
scene auntie peppa also gives her a fair
number of death glares throughout the
movie mirabelle is just very unpopular
in the family but watching it as many
times as i have i actually think that
abuela is the one that gets the best
character beats like here after this
moment he wants five babies
wonderful abuela who's always focused on
appearances picks the one imperfect
flower out of isabella's hair there's
also here where she's sweeping up the
flowers from her earlier conversation
with isabella or here where she
subconsciously adjusts her earrings when
talking about having to meet the other
family because again she's all about
appearing perfect but as you can
probably imagine listening to we don't
talk about bruno one too many times
starts to do funny things to your head
and my mind started to do the thing that
it always does it got dark see somewhere
after the 45th viewing it really started
to sink in that the people in the
magical encounter have been living there
undisturbed for 50 years nobody has
entered and nobody has left you know the
mountains around the encampto are pretty
tall and we know this for a fact because
the co-director jared bush has said
multiple times that the family hasn't
left and that any new additions have
come from within the existing encanto
community which can only mean one thing
in breeding since there's only a small
number of people in this isolated
village and since it's been 50 years of
them being stuck there is this a
genetically stagnant population do they
have to worry about inbreeding has it
happened yet will it happen well i
looked into it because of course i did
and for as stupid as this question may
seem on the surface the answer wound up
being fascinating because it seems to
have some huge ramifications for the
ending of the movie and it puts the
return of the magic into a brand new
light so get ready and let's turn the
sound up because now it's time for a
theory roundup as a quick refresher or
for those of you who never saw my
episode on count chocula over on food
theory inbreeding is the mating of
people who are closely related through
ancestry it's a practice that's probably
most associated with rich high-powered
families in ye olden days like the
hapsburgs who would inbreed as a means
of keeping their bloodlines pure it
ensured that no new dna was getting in
the family why would this be such a
problem well as most of you probably
know by now there are dominant and
recessive genes that dictate what traits
a child gets and many genetic diseases
are recessive traits this usually isn't
a problem when we out breed what we're
really doing is shuffling our dna around
to make sure that there's genetic
diversity that way even if we have a
recessive genetic disease our partner
likely doesn't meaning that the child is
protected however inbreeding does the
exact opposite of this blood-related
people have similar dna which greatly
increases the chances of both partners
carrying a dangerous recessive allele
and passing it onto their offspring so
while inbreeding was historically used
to keep the bloodlines pure the practice
was actually amplifying the problems
that were floating around in the dna
chains generation after generation this
tended to result in each generation
having decreased stamina size and
fertility while increasing the amount of
infant mortality but inbreeding isn't
just a problem for the rich noble
families who are trying to stay pure
since the beginning of time small remote
populations have historically struggled
with inbreeding because of their
shallower gene pools a real world
example of this can be found on the
isolated atoll in the western pacific
named pingalap also known as the island
of the colorblind the population is
descended from 20 people who survived
typhoon which hit the island in the 18th
century one of the survivors was a
carrier of achromatopsia a rare
recessive disorder which causes total
colorblindness with such a tiny gene
pool remaining today one tenth of the
island's population is totally
colorblind in contrast here in the
states colorblindness normally affects 1
in 33 000 americans with 1 in 100 as
carriers instead of out breeding to
potentially cause recessive alleles to
disappear from the population inbreeding
makes those things more common so
knowing all this it stands to reason
that maybe the village inside the
encanto could share a similar fate they
too are an isolated village with a small
population size did any of you guys ever
have to read a hundred years of solitude
in english class was actually an 11th
grade summer reading requirement for me
anyway it's a 1967 novel written by
author gabrielle garcia marquez stop me
if you've heard this one before the book
is all about the buendia family a family
that lives in a small remote village in
colombia the book is full of magical
realism a surprising amount of yellow
butterflies and inbreeding considering
that encanto also features a small
remote colombian village with magical
powers and yellow butterflies it stood
to reason that maybe the inbreeding was
a match too just saying if the
genetically undifferentiated shoe fits
wear it to get things started i wanted
to get a sense of how many people
actually live in the encanto in the
first place i mean it seems like a small
community but then again i could be
completely misjudging things after
looking at a few key group scenes i was
actually surprised by my tally i first
counted everyone who attended antonio's
gift ceremony in the stage directions of
the script it says that the whole
village is there it's also the moment
that features the most people in one
place so it felt like a good indicator
for the overall size of the community i
also counted the number of people who
appeared during the family made the
degal opening number but i quickly
learned that the number wouldn't be
exact since we see a couple people
multiple times i also did my best to
count the number of people who came to
rebuild the house at the end of the film
after doing all of these counts and
calculations while also trying to
eliminate as many confirmed duplicates
as i could my best estimate for the
number of people living in the village
is anywhere between 310 and 320. so
that's the current population but in
order to see how the population has
grown over the last 50 years we also
have to know how many people entered the
encanto in the first place the best
place we have to calculate this number
is this scene near the end of the movie
when we witness pedro mandirgaal leading
a group of refugees away from their
homes we get to see a wide shot of them
while the group is crossing the river
and though it doesn't show us everyone
you can definitely count 55 people
consisting of 24 men 17 women and 14
kids 9 girls 5 boys i don't think it's
significantly more than this because as
they're crossing the river they suddenly
see riders storming at them from the
distance the group hurries across the
water and hides in the woods while pedro
hangs back to protect the group as he
says goodbye to alma we see the
villagers running past them since allman
pedro were at the front of the pack in
the beginning it means literally
everyone in the group had to pass them
during that 20 seconds of screen time it
takes for the riders to catch up as such
it really doesn't seem like there are
hundreds of people in this group since
there are several people who i didn't
see during the river crossing running
past alma and pedro while he kisses the
babies i added in an extra 20 putting
our initial population here at somewhere
around 75. once you subtract the 14 kids
the extra men and the 10 of the group
who have fertility issues which is the
number that was decided upon by the
national institute of health i think in
a perfect world scenario it's safe to
assume that there were a total of 25
couples in this initial group that are
able to have children now over 50 years
the population went from 75 to 300 plus
it might seem like a big leap but in
1950 the births per woman average in
colombia was 6.4 to be fair in 1900
colombia's child mortality rate was
estimated to be approximately 42 percent
meaning that almost 42 of all children
born wouldn't survive past their fifth
birthday due to ailments like pneumonia
and tb however this village also has
juliette madrigal who could probably
take a break carrying people covered
with cactus spines to save the lives of
some sick babies long story short
between better healthcare a lack of
conflict and a clean water source we
would expect most if not all of the
children to survive i mean that is kind
of the point of the encanto after all
it's meant to be a paradise also while
we're on the subject no julieta is not a
cheat code for solving inbreeding she
doesn't seem to be able to cure genetic
issues because as we clearly see in the
movie she's able to cure the symptoms of
augustine's bee allergy but not the
actual genetic causes behind the problem
she can cure ailments like swelling but
not the underlying genetics issue so no
inbreeding's still at play okay so
knowing all of this information do the
people of the encanto have to worry
about inbreeding well in 1980 a
long-standing idea in species
restoration theories was the so-called
5500 rule the idea behind it is that 50
people capable of creating children
could prevent the immediate risk of
inbreeding and 500 would help combat
genetic drift 50 huh well that's exactly
where our count of encanto's population
wound up so the madrigales village is
riding dangerously close to the line it
also isn't helping their case that many
more recent articles claim that the
numbers from the 1980s are way too low
new estimates range from 98 to 150 to
160 to 10 000 and 14 000. other articles
suggest that the proper ratios here
should be 505 000 instead of 5500.
finally in an article from science focus
entitled how do small and isolated
tribes cope with inbreeding it states
that there are tribal customs to prevent
inbreeding but quote inbreeding only
becomes a serious problem when the
population drops below 50 or so
basically reading the relevant
scientific literature there seems to be
no one consensus which sucks again
because encanto's village is right there
on the bubble so i had to call in the
big guns i asked my buddy austin from
the show the science over on game theory
to design a computer model that would
simulate mating patterns for encanto's
village and then track the gene
combinations that were being spread to
offspring from there we would program in
populations the size we calculated for
the movie and create best and worst case
scenarios of mating patterns to see if
and when inbreeding would occur because
there were so many hypotheticals at play
i felt it was best to keep it simple by
keeping a 50 50 ratio of men to women
being born after running a few dozen
rounds of the simulation what we found
was shocking yes for as perfect as the
encanto was there would be guaranteed
inbreeding the best best best case
scenario was that it would take six
generations for the inbreeding to start
to become inevitable assuming about 25
years per generation the computer said
it would happen sometime around 129
years but in order to get even remotely
that far you'd have to be very careful
about who was marrying who in order to
get even oh
oh
my
gosh i've spoken to the guzmans about
mariano's proposal to isabella he wants
five babies
wonderful such a fine young man with our
perfect isabella will bring a new
generation of magical blessings and make
both of our families stronger
they knew at the very least abuela knew
that's why marriages had to be arranged
in this world like isabella marrying
mariano to make sure everyone was
staying genetically diverse it is to
make the family stronger literally the
only way to get six generations into
this thing without any inbreeding is to
carefully track and control genetic
diversity and mating patterns abuela was
the puppet master except there's only so
long that they can last even if
everything is perfectly controlled you
still only have a few generations left
to go here when we join in with
mirabelle's story they're sitting at the
50-year mark nearly halfway through the
best-case scenario three generations
deep according to our calculations
planning out each generation goes up in
complexity squared which becomes more
and more difficult to manage it's a
fortunate thing then that the magic died
and the mountain cracked in half when it
did it allowed the people inside to
leave and more importantly it allowed
new blood to come in it's almost like
the magic wasn't dying because the
family was growing apart maybe instead
the magic was dying because the family
was growing a bit too close together but
hey that's just a theory a film theory
cuts
[Music]
[Music]
you